c'est un peu le manège ultime la
transition entre les différents étages
de la fusée c'est aussi super dynamique
un étage qui s'arrêtent tu as
l'impression que tu est arrêté net au
milieu du ciel un étage qui repart tu
prends un coup de pied aux fesses et là
tu repars coller au siège que ressentons
au décollage vers l'espace comment
fait-on les gestes du quotidien
à quoi ressemble une sortie dans
l'espace à l'extérieur de la station
spatiale internationale
comment se passe d'ailleurs aussi le
retour sur terre et puis des questions
plus terre-à-terre comme par exemple
combien gagne un astronaute salut c'est
hugo j'espère que vous allez bien après
françois hollande qui nous a révélé les
secrets du quotidien d'un président de
la république après aussi s'ériger en
off et nous et maurane qui nous ont
dévoilé les secrets de la vie d'un
espion on revient cette fois ci avec un
troisième épisode et un troisième métier
c'est au tour de thomas pesquet rien que
ça de répondre aux questions que l'on se
pose tous sur le métier d'astronaute et
ce alors qu'il a effectué deux missions
au sein de l' iss alors il est passé au
bureau on a pris le temps de discuter
east et passionnant d'écouter ses
réponses alors n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour ne pas louper les vidéos
suivantes de cette série qui visiblement
vous plaît beaucoup et je vous laisse
donc avec les puces
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de voie toute tracée pour
devenir astronaute il n'y a pas d'école
d'astronautes ya pas de trucs où tu peux
t'inscrire qui va ta sur une formation
en fait quand tu regarde le profil des
gens souvent ces profils quand même un
peu scientifique et technique il ya
beaucoup de pilotes aussi à des gens qui
viennent au milieu un peu plus militaire
il faut avoir
une première carrière ou deux parfois tu
vois il ya des gens qu'on travaillait
comme ingénieur sur une plateforme
pétrolière et qui sont devenus pilotes
après où on aime bien peu ces profils
variés et mixte il faut trois choses
importantes pour devenir astronaute il
faut un parcours un peu académique parce
qu'on va évoluer dans un monde quand
même super technique super technologique
donc sans avoir de prix nobel tu vois et
on n'a pas besoin d'être les meilleurs
du monde mais il faut quand même avoir
un certain bagage qui va permettre de
comprendre un petit peu tout ça et
d'évoluer dans ce monde compliqué bon ça
bah tu me prouve au moment de on va dire
l'entretien d'embauché ou ta sélection
après le deuxième truc important c'est
ce qu'on appelle le côté opérationnel
donc ça ça veut dire qu'il faut aller
s'être mis dans des conditions réelles
si tu connais bien les scientifiques qui
sont allés sur le terrain tu vois moi
j'ai des collègues qui fait de la
recherche contre les mollahs en afrique
ou qui étaient sur des qui était sur les
brise glace en antarctique des choses
comme ça donc il faut cette expérience
un peu sur le terrain ça peut être aussi
dans télé loisirs terrain gac a plein de
saut en parachute ou des choses comme ça
ça peut être ça peut être validé un gars
ou une fille et le troisième truc
important c'est le côté international
s'être un peu exporté avoir étudié et
travaillé hors de la france on va dire
pour nous français puis être à l'aise
avec les langues ça c'est important site
à ces trois trucs l'académique terrain
et impressionnable exactement si tu as
et trois trucs là et tu peux t'inscrire
à la sélection et à des bonnes chances
au moins au début ensuite il faut
réussir toutes les épreuves de la
sélection
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien dire astronautes alors
pourquoi il ya plein de lerus disait
cosmonautes à la base cosmonautes c'est
le voyageur du cosmos nom qui va dans
l'espace ça c'est bien les américains
disent astronautes le voyageur désastre
des étoiles ça c'est moins correct
étymologiquement ce que les étoiles
c'est quand même loin nous on reste au
voisinage de la terre il ya le terme
spationautes qui arrive et ça s'était
plutôt dans les années dans les années
90 pour parler des astronautes français
du cna ski bosses et notamment sur le
programme hermès alors par extension
maintenant il ya des gens qui
considèrent que spationautes vers le
terme français ne suis pas entièrement
d'accord ce camp français astronautes
existe et puis si tu veux c'est c'est un
peu bizarre de
d'avoir un nom différent en fonction de
la nationalité du gars qui exerce la
profession c'est une réponse super
longue pour te dire que les trois sondes
les trois sont corrects mais astronautes
moi ça me va bien en plus on parle quand
même beaucoup anglais aujourd'hui dans
le monde international donc on a
tendance à un temps c'est à dire ça
[Musique]
on va commencer au lancement le
lancement tu arrives à peu près deux
heures et demie avant tu t'es préparer
c'est quand même assez solennel ce que
tu dis au revoir à tout le monde à ta
famille tu penses à vraiment dire tout
ce que tu avais envie de dire parce que
normalement tout le monde revient
toujours mais c'est quand même un truc
un peu compliqué tu vas tu installes et
tu fais tout et vérification c'est très
technique c'est très pro ça parle pas
tout le monde est concentré compte à
rebours est là bas quand ça décolle
écoute ses sensations assez d'indiens
l'accélération sa plaque sur ton siège
tu sens très très nettement que tu que
tu quittes la terne l'accélération lé
constantin pendant huit minutes 48 à peu
près pour le pour le soyouz un peu plus
pour le falcon 9 tu fais que accéléré et
c'est ça vraiment qu'il va t'emmener en
orbite c'est pas tellement d'aller au
quai compliqué ce qu'il faut aller très
très vite donc tu accélères tu accélères
tout le temps une accélération qui
varient mais qui est toujours présente
et il ya des vibrations il ya beaucoup
de bruit du dialogue avec le centre de
contrôle tu as des actions a fermé mais
globalement
c'est un peu le manège ultime la
transition entre les différences des
étages de la fusée c'est aussi super
dynamique un étage qui s'arrêtent tu as
l'impression que tu est arrêté net au
milieu du ciel un étage qui repart battu
prend un coup de pied aux fesses et là
tu repars coller au siège était toujours
sanglé dans ton siège strappé très fort
parce que bas 6 passe quoi que ce soit
tu peux être éjecté la cape la capsule
peut être éjecté en une grande poêle et
rouge sur laquelle on tire c'est le
siège éjectable mais pour la capsule
entière par individuelle et ensuite tout
ça se calme au boudin au bout du moment
où on arrive en orbite on se détache du
dernier étage est là avec notre petite
capsule encore une fois que soit le
soyouz ou coup dragon on est en vol
orbital c'est à dire qu'on a été
injectée sur une orbite est content
ondes avec beaucoup de vitesse autour de
la terre comme un boulet de canon donc
c'est assez c'est assez peaceful en fait
c'est assez calme et la transition est
génial parce que après cette phase super
dynamique avec énormément de
d'accélération est bien là tout d'un
coup c'est le silence
on va toujours très vite évidemment non
sans plus est cette vitesse et cette
accélération c'est la première fois où
tout flotte à bord de la capsule donc
toi tu es toujours attaché à ce moment
là mais tu fait flotter ton stylo des
trucs comme ça pour bien vérifier
d'ailleurs on a un indicateur de gravité
entre guillemets qui est juste en
général est un petit un petit jouet en
peluche qui vient des enfants dans les
membres de l'équipage qui au bout d'une
ficelle tant que la ficelle est tendue
c'est à dire qu'on est encore en train
d'accélérer et au bout d'un an mon bout
d'un moment quand ça suit celle comment
se construit commence à flotter ça veut
dire que ça y est on arrivé en orbite
donc un peu par dérision on appelle ça
l'indicateur de gravité fall plus sorti
lille et on fait nos trajectoires et on
va s'arrimer à la station spatiale juste
avant l'arrimage ormeno scaphandre parce
que si jamais il se passer un truc pas
généré si on tape un peu fort dans la
paroisse on veut pas dépressurisé donc
on se remet en scaphandre on arrive on
égalise les pressions on ouvre le saas
dans l'aveu scaphandre ans dans la
station spatiale à la concernant cette
phase d'accélération quelle différence
est ce que tu fais par exemple avec de
la formule un conte assure-t-elle la
formule 1 la plus rapide du monde
accélère un peu plus de 2 ce
de kilomètres heure par seconde et nous
on est encore plus rapide que ça donc ça
veut dire que tu as l'accélération la
plus rapide que tu peux avoir sur terre
mais que le fond pendant allez quoi 10
12 15 secondes maxi ensuite ça freine ça
repart tandis que nous on va vraiment
accéléré pendant quasiment neuf minutes
donc au final on est à des vitesses j'ai
à dire supersonique mené bien au delà du
supersonique mon à 28 km heure c'est des
chiffres qui sont tellement grand qu'on
se rend pas compte mais 28 km heure ces
10 12 minutes entre paris et new york 1
[Musique]
quand on dit qu'on est à 2g et 3g 4g
c'est des termes de pilotes de chasse
notamment voltige ou de formule 1 donc
ça veut dire 2g ça veut dire ton corps
pèse deux fois son poids 3g 4g savent
que si je lève mon bras comme ça en fait
plutôt que lever je sais pas ça fait
quoi 7 kg un bras j'en sais rien je dis
n'importe quoi je dis est bien là ce
sera cette fois 88 kg donc tu vois ça
commence à devenir un peu difficile tu
ressens à la lecture sans retour tu as
la peau du visage qui est un peu tiré tu
as tout les organes qui sont un peu
crevé
il ya notamment une technique qui est de
bloquer sa cage thoracique parce que si
tu la bloque pas en position haute si tu
restes en position basse après la 4g
tarifs plus à la halle à la volaille et
du coup pour respirer un volume super
réduit de tes poumons donc en fait faut
arriver à bloquer sa cage thoracique en
position haute respirez à l'intérieur de
ça et comme ça au moins tu as tout le
volume disponible donc la cécité et ses
petites techniques comme ça
[Musique]
fait autour de la terre situe en une
heure et demie dans des couches et des
levers de soleil jouant nuit jour nuit
on n'arrête pas d'enchaîner évidemment
on peut pas travailler comme ça donc on
a pris une référence un peu arbitraire
c'est celle du temps universel méridien
de greenwich on se cale dessus tous les
jours le matin quand on se lève on
allume les lumières le premier qui se
lèvent allume les lumières à bord de l
iss le dernier qui se couche les états
ont gardé un rythme qui a gardé un
rythme humain en fête est aussi alors
pour nous déjà pour ton rythme personnel
pour ton corps parce qu on a évolué
comme ça on est on est branché comme ça
dans notre cerveau mais aussi pour pour
travailler de manière cohérente avec les
équipes au sol
[Musique]
recherche scientifique on parle on va en
parler un petit peu plus et c'est un peu
le but de la station spatiale c'est un
des deux buts de la station spatiale
donc une expérience de physiologie ou
telle ou telle cobayes donc c'est un thé
camarades qui va te faire des prises de
sang ou tu cours sur le tapis roulant et
des électrodes sur la tête on mesure
tout un tas de constantes de ton corps
ça peut être un peu n'importe quoi ou
physique des matériaux on a des
installations de recherche partout dans
la station spatiale
avec des microscopes des centrifugeuses
des congélateurs fonds se met dans des
conditions qu'on peut pas reproduire sur
terre justement les conditions d'un
pesanteur mais pas seulement on a aussi
des conditions de radiation et c'est
qu'on peut pas vraiment reproduire sur
terre pour avoir accès à des choses qui
sur terre sont inaccessibles
scientifiquement et faire des
découvertes après on en voit les
résultats dans les laboratoires publics
d'hébreu publie des brevets etc ça c'est
une chose et la deuxième chose dans les
ss c'est pas une fin en soi c'est
vraiment une étape sur la route de
l'exploration on veut aller plus loin on
veut retourner vers la lune on veut
aller vers mars pour plein de raisons
dont on peut parler et celia cesse
aujourd'hui qui nous aident à faire les
affaires des découvertes les progrès les
avancées techniques technologiques et
opérationnelles qui vont nous rendre
capables demain d'aller sur la lune et
sur mars ont fait aussi le l'entretien
de la station donc on est plombier on
est électricien on peut on a les mains
dans le cambouis la moitié du temps
parce qu'il faut la maintenir en bon
état cette station
[Musique]
on fait deux heures et demie de sport
par jour pour rester en forme sinon on
perdrait trop de masse musculaire massot
unique donc on a un vélo d'appartement
on va dire un tapis roulant sur lequel
on est attaché avec des sans raison de
la pesanteur ouais ouais c'est ça parce
que ton corps si tu veux tous les
muscles en concert sur terre tout ça on
s'en sert pas du tout à bord de la
station c'est facile on flotte c'est
génial mais sauf que du coup ça provoque
une atrophie de plein de muscles et bah
du coup on lève je dis enlève de la
fonte s'est évidemment pas de la fonte
parce que impesanteur mais c'est s'aider
cylindres pneumatiques avec des
résistances
[Musique]
des éléments importants c'est vraiment
un côté psychologie il faut être être
adaptable il faut savoir communiquer
savoir expliquer mais aussi savoir
écouter il faut être leader quand il a
besoin et parfois pas du tout au
contraire être capable aussi de faire ce
qu'on me dit sans rien demander
il ya tous ces aspects là qui sont pas
ce qu'on recherchait au début des eaux
des bus on envoyait un peu plus tôt
génère des cow boys dans l'espace mais
c'est un petit peu ça on vous les gars
super super résistant parce qu'on savait
pas un peu guerrier un peu militaire etc
maintenant on n'a pas besoin de superman
superwoman on a besoin de gens qui
savent travail en équipe etc
deuxièmement on s'entraîne pour ça on va
se mettre dans des situations
compliquées aussi au sol on est resté
neuf jours dans un caisson sous l'eau
grand plus petit que cette salle là on
est resté en spéléologie aussi pendant
un moment tu es dans le noir tu as plus
de références de temps et on va se
stresser alors c'était limite un peu
nationalité limite est toujours en
groupe toujours en groupe toujours en
équipe avec des buts avec un menu une
structure qui rappelle un peu celle dont
on parle à un instant pour l'igas est
[Musique]
tu sais on nous on voit là les
astronautes quand ils réalisent leur vol
spatial mais s'est plaint des équipes
sont là pour nous aider il ya notamment
des médecins et des psychologues qui
sont là pour nous suivre si jamais on
avait un problème on peut toujours leur
parler la grande crainte c'est c'est
aussi le problème qui arrivent sur terre
pendant que toi tu es dans l'espace est
de se dire vrai il va se passer un truc
horrible un gros coup dur at-talah quoi
t'es pas là et tu peux pas revenir tu es
parti six mois ça se passe le premier
jour de la mission on va pas trop
décembre quoi et d'ailleurs ça fait
partie des questions un peu compliqué on
ne demande pas mal au début de la
mission s'ils se passe un truc vraiment
grave un truc vraiment pas terrible
est-ce que comment tu veux le savoir
comment tu vas être informés des ja est
ce que tu veux qu'on te le dise lui
prépare pour une sortie extravéhiculaire
tentera d'enfiler son scaphandre pour
être dehors 7h dans le vide de l'espace
a envie d'avoir la mauvaise nouvelle à
ce moment-là ou d'attendre le moment que
tu reviens on se prépare à toutes les
éventualités malheureusement celle là
c'est aussi l'éventualité qu'on a en
tête
[Musique]
alors c'est un peu l'image d'epinal de
l'astronaute us est le casque le
scaphandre etc et c'est un peu le rêve
dans le rêve parce que dans la station
c'est super mais d'être dehors c'est
encore plus dingue en fait c'est
énormément de préparation quand tu sors
de la station tu as tu exposés à du
risque en fait le risque c'est quoi
c'est bien évidemment il n'y a pas de
c'est le vide à l'extérieur de la
station qu'il n'y a pas de quoi respirer
les écarts de température sont extrêmes
en fait t'as pas l'atmosphère le rôle de
la terre pour pour réguler un peu tout
ça donc quand tu es au soleil tu monte à
150 degrés en surface et quand tu es à
l'ombre de la terre si tu restes
longtemps tu descends à moins 100 degrés
tu vas voir ça sur ton scaffa évidemment
t'as pas envie d'avoir ça sur ta peau ou
pour ton système donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a un scaphandre c'est pour ça
qu'on prend pleins de précaution il
s'agirait pas de se détacher et de
lâcher la station spatiale on va pas
tomber mais si on dérive tout doucement
rien qui va nous arrêter donc on va
dériver tout doucement infiniment que
c'est pour ça qu'on est toujours attaché
qu'en général on lui même attaché avec
deux longes où un fils de sécurité un
fil d'ariane y'a pas d'improvisation une
fois que tu es dehors tout a été préparé
tout a été étudié les équipes au centre
de contrôle sont là à la radio pour dire
quasiment ton moindre geste
est déjà à bord de la station quand tu
te prépares tu prépares le scaphandre et
puis donc voilà au bout de cinq six
heures le jour de la sortie
extravéhiculaire on est dans le
scaphandre on a tous nos outils accroché
parce que tout est accroché à toi
évidemment tu peux rien laisser flotter
on se met dans le sas c'est vraiment
laid nos coéquipiers qui nous prépare
une fois que tu es dans le scaphandre et
qui te met qui te four un peu dans le
sas qui ferme la porte derrière toi on
ouvre on sort hélas la première la
première fois que tu bascules c'est fou
parce que ça peut être de nuit ou de
jour ses limites plus impressionnant de
nu parce qu'il ya vraiment un espèce de
grand trouble
quitte à petit avec tu aspires mais deux
jours quand elle a toujours le sas et à
la terre qui défile à 400 km tu fais pas
le malin et donc tu sors la première
fois que tu sors il faut apprendre à ton
cerveau que tu vas pas tomber si je
lâche la station mais que je me pousse
pas je reste en place alors c'est vrai
jamais très stable mais mais je vais pas
tomber par contre ton cerveau il ne sait
pas parce que toi tu as évolué sur terre
sur terre tu lâches la paroisse en
escalade il a 28 ans et après tu vas
faire ton boulot tu as plein objective
tu vas vis et des choses davis est
installé nous c'était un panneau solaire
de 17 m ça peut prendre du temps mais
c'est cette heure et ensuite retour à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
jusqu'à france et un vaisseau spatial
tas de dans ta radio pour la
communication bouteilles d'oxygène tu as
même une mini propulsion à la gravity
alors georges qui suivait dérivés
vraiment tout petit a une chance de
revenir c'est tout le professeur c'est
vraiment au cas où il ya un problème ou
à revenir ouais ah ouais ouais alors on
a un fil d'ariane qui se déroule qui est
toujours à crochète et met parfois en
fonction de ce que tu fais ça va ça va
se coincer à des endroits c'est pas
toujours hyper facile tu as des longes
et puis si vraiment tout ça ça devait
rater tu as une petite manette sur le
côté ça va déployer un petit un petit
contrôleur et à des propulseurs on
s'entraîne à ça en réalité virtuelle
pour se re piloter vers l'astéroïde de
sus il vraiment réellement dessus ouais
t'as une chance donc ça on n'est jamais
arrivé oui mais on n'a pas envie que ça
arrive
[Musique]
t'imagines c'est comme si ton poids
c'était de l'eau dans un évier puis tout
d'un coup tu été enlevés le le siphon
enfin le bouchon et hop ton poids a
disparu comme ça c'est vraiment cette
sensation là t'es tu es libéré de ton
poids qui était un truc qui te
évidemment te poses et devient côté
perte de contrôle qu'il faut accepter et
après il faut réapprendre à se mouvoir
ce que et au début tu as pas du tout
l'habitude ya des gens qui nagent en a
c'est trop marrant parce qu'il ya des
gens qui nagent saab sion a rien que là
j'ai un compteur le seul truc que tu
peux faire c'est action réaction tu
pousses sur quelque chose ça va toi te
propulser et ensuite tu pousses sur
autre chose donc tu vois les astronautes
qui se déplacent comme ça par petites
touches parfois même avec les pieds tu
accroches il ya plein de l'espèce de
mains courantes ou des rails qui sont
faits pour ça mais il ya cette phase de
lâcher prise et de réapprendre les buts
tu vois les gars les gars je dis les
gars mais moi aussi en début tu te
connais tu négocies malte en virage la
drogue classique c'est une fois que tu
es partie avec de la vitesse donc y'a
rien qui tu arrêtes tu peux pas freiner
c'est impossible je te dis seul truc
c'est action-réaction t'attrape une arme
et ça te fait fuser à l'intérieur mais
ça tu accélères et si tu pars france qui
marche une fois aux deux c était un peu
trop confiant un peu trop la confiance
arrive bien à fond un peu tu en
orientation bizarre et là tu veux
prendre la barre tu fais pas gaffe tu
parles invaincu en même temps et là tu
rates la barre est là mais tu vas tu vas
tout le monde tu craches et parfois tu
craches un peu fort
[Musique]
ben en fait tu du moment que du moment
que tu peux dormir n'importe où
n'importe comment dans la station t'as
pas besoin de reposer sur quelque chose
on t'aime pas besoin une surface molle
comme un matelas un oreiller ou quoi que
ce soit ce qu'on fait quand même c'est
qu'on a des cabines donc en général pour
avoir un peu quand tu dois au moins tu
as la porte fermée il fait noir tu es un
peu tranquille il ya un peu moins de
bruit mais en général on s'attache au
mur donc on a des espèces de duvet qui
sont faits pour l'impesanteur qu'on
enfile avec des troupes pour les bras un
peu si tu veux tu ferme ton duvet tu
peux mettre le le chapeau ou pas faim la
partie pour la tête ou pas et et ben tu
dors comme ça donc tu dors accroché au
mur et donc ceux qui dorment sur les
côtés ils peuvent dormir la tête en haut
mais tu pourras aussi bien dormir à
terme on voit celui qui dort au plafond
mais alors comme ça et celui qui dort
sur plancher d'or comme ça après pour
manger par exemple
là c'est pareil il faut réapprendre faut
tout réapprendre quand tu arrives dans
l'installation on a nos espèces de
pochettes de nourriture qui sont fermés
un peu on a lu on les met au four c'est
le four si les plaques chauffantes avec
espèce de petit ressort qui maintiennent
aux pochettes dessus pour qui les
contactent tu les coupes comme ça et
après tu mangeais avec ta cuir alors là
il faut faire gaffe c'est que tout
flotte donc tu peux rien posé sur la
table sauf si à du velcro velcro c'est
notre ami à bord de la station il y en a
partout sur ta cuillère il ya du velcro
sur ta boîte de nuit en voiture ya duel
crocs sur ton pantalon et du velcro sur
ta tablette ya du velcro tout le temps
que tu mange du riz tu vois les petits
grains de riz sa part partout faire
super gaffe et justement si le coupé les
cheveux pareil comment ça se passe
puisque les cheveux c'est petit par les
fusions ouest les coupes il part tout
comme est ce que tu les mets ça on tue
légère ouais et en plus ça peut être un
problème pour nous sur 7 mai dans tes
yeux c'est quand même un peu dangereux
et même pour tous nos équipements si on
a les ventilateurs quand même pas mal de
technologie tu peux pas te permettre de
balancer des débris que ce soit des
petits cheveux
la poussière du riz ou autre donc là
pour la coupe de cheveux des gens se
coupe les cheveux l'un l'autre donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a et ronchin peu
bizarre gouvernement parce qu'une
personne est coiffeur professionnel tu
veux donc c'est tondeuse et il ya un
gros un tuyau d'aspirateur qui est
branché sur sur la tondeuse et en gros
tout ce que tout ce que tu coupes s'est
immédiatement inspiré ensuite tu jettes
le sac de l'aspirateur
[Musique]
ça gagne ça gagne bien sa vie mais ça
gagne pas non plus que les gens
s'imaginent estivale à l'agencé spatiale
européenne ase une grille des salaires
ces fonctionnaires européens situe donc
c'est assez encadré hadjira tu peut la
trouver sur internet
nous ont gagné plus ni moins que tous
les autres personnes de lézat en fait de
l' agence donc on est très très très
loin des salaires de footballeurs ou
parfois les gens s'imaginent des trucs
dingues oh c'est pas le cas moi j'estime
que je gagne bien ma vie si tu veux mais
par exemple an par rapport au mois
j'étais pilote avant on va dire c'est
peut-être un petit peu moins que ça leur
convient
[Musique]
a réussi à apprivoiser leurs beats
proche de la terre maintenant on va
aller un peu plus loin je pense très
honnêtement que cette tendance elle va
continuer nous quand je dis nous c'est
les astronautes institutionnels nasa et
les agences spatiales européenne et
autres ont essayé d'aller de plus en
plus loin de libérer un peu ce cet
espace autour de la terre et ensuite
bailly bon il peut y avoir des velléités
privé que privé que ce soit pour la
recherche ou pour exploiter d'autres
manières mais c'est un peu ça l'idée
nous on explore on défriche on apprend
les règles on s'approprie mais on n'a
pas vocation à faire ça éternellement
une fois que c'est fait on va un peu
plus loin à faire ça ailleurs une fois
que c'est fait on va un peu plus loin on
va continuer comme ça
[Musique]
quand tu reviens déjà physiquement c'est
difficile ton corps c'est adapté tu vois
tes muscles ton système sanguin et c'est
ton système déclic dont tu reviens tu es
plus adapté à la vie sur terre tu es
malade et a le mal de mer enfin le mal
de retours sur terre puissance 10 me
tâte a mal au dos tu as mal aux pieds tu
as mal partout ce que tu étais plus
habituée à porter ton poids etc et
surtout ce qui est le côté bluesy les
deux choses d'abord tu as perdu tu es
super pouvoirs de volée devant les
fameux les fameux super pouvoirs et ça
c'est quand même un peu raide
et puis deuxièmement fin c'était ton
rêve pour nous c'était tous notre est
d'aller dans l'espace donc tu vis ton
rêve après tu reviens tu dis bon alors
je fais quoi et c'est ce côté là aussi
qu'est ce qui est un peu il faut se re
motiver parce que ben voila quand tu es
dans la station spatiale tout est clair
qu'on a tous les buts il ya qu un seul
interlocuteur c'est le centre de
contrôle tout le monde tire dans le même
sens c'est une mission c'est
l'exploration tout le monde est tendu
vers le même objectif après au sol c'est
pas comme ça tu sais c'est très diverses
et très variée ya plein de priorités
différentes qui se télescopent etc etc
ce côté expéditions missions sont précis
précise et ses énergies équipe tout ça
c'est difficile ça existe un sur terre
mais c'est difficile à retrouver donc il
faut il faut retrouver ça il ya plein
d'autres projets on verra ce que c'est
la suite très bien mais coûte merci
beaucoup pour ton temps avec plaisir
[Musique]